The joe rogan experience.
This is going to be a rough transition,
but seeings how I have to go do my podcast pretty quick on the topic of
podcasts.
You know,
I'm being sued.
Yes.
And uh,
explain that to people because it's one of the dumbest fucking lawsuits I've
ever heard in my life.
But there's people that make a living off of these types of lawsuits right
there.
Yeah.
Called Patent trolls.
They buy up patents and their lawyers and it Sorta,
I think it's this country at its worst.
I really do.
It's they buy patents and then they shoe companies saying they're using stealing
or unlawfully using their technology.
And sometimes when you're buying technology,
there's a real good argument to that.
Like that technology is a part of this thing that you're selling.
And without that technology,
which is patented,
your technology while you're selling would not exist.
Right.
And I get that part and I support innovation and people should be paid for for
intellectual property and creative ideas.
But this is a weird one.
This is what is the exact term that,
that they have a patent on the exact cause they have a patent on a playlist.
Yes.
So on anything in a serial order,
right,
right.
Like even blogs I evidently anything that's comes out on a Monday and then the
next one comes out on a Tuesday or this song is above that song and the song's
number three and that song's number seven.
That's what they claim to have dominion over.
So if you have a blog and you enter into the blog,
like a blog entry number one,
you know a Adam goes to do podcasts to talk about this lawsuit,
they could sue you for that.
Like they own a piece of that,
a serialized message that you're putting on a website.
Yeah.
Numbered message that that's correct.
That's insane.
Well this insane because if it's true then really everything on the Internet's
got to go away.
Everything.
Could you imagine if they bought up everything on the Internet with one sneaky
move?
Like one sneaky move,
one patent with the judge says,
look,
the guy's got a point.
He owns everything in serialized form.
Well,
the problem is is I don't think the judge or the jury is going to think they
have a point.
Unfortunately,
in order to make our point that they don't have a point,
it's going to cost one point $5 million.
Holy Shit.
That's what patent litigation costs.
That's what the legal fees are going to be.
That's what,
that's what I've been quoted.
Oh my God.
I've been quoted 1.25 to 1.5 wow.
Yeah.
That's stunning.
I never would have thought it would be that high.
So are they always spring hate a lot,
so it was,
is that what it is?
It's all the lawyers.
That's what it is.
It's all the lawyers and that.
How much work did they have to do here,
Joe?
For me it's like first off,
I spent $50,000 trying to get a change of fucking venue.
These guys are in eastern Texas.
That's where they set up because eastern Texas is famous for him.
Leave to their types of folk.
Yeah.
If to this type of thing.
Patent troll lawsuits.
I don't live in eastern Texas and my businesses in eastern Texas and they don't
live in eastern Texas either.
That's just where they've hung their shingle and they hung their shingle
specifically because this is a place it's advantageous to do things like this
well is it's what you would do if you were company that bought up other people's
technology and then tried to sue other businesses and make money off of them.
You're going to maximize that.
The possibility of you getting an outcome that's in your favor and you'll do it
on the moon if you have to.
Now,
if these people come to you with some sort of a settlement,
like if they said,
hey,
you know,
you're using our technology,
we would like five bucks a month.
Like anything along those lines.
Yes.
$3 million.
Whoa.
And this because they've,
they've won these before the same company.
They got $8 million from apple,
right?
Yeah.
It's,
it's unclear what I'm doing with them and what they're doing with me,
but it's a pretty simple equation,
which is I just said,
look,
all the guys in podcasting need to kind of band together and we need to fight
them and then we need to beat them.
And then once we beat them,
then their beat,
because they can't go after you or mark Marin or whoever once we beat them.
But if we allow this to just go away,
it's not going to,
if we say,
well,
let's just put it aside and you know,
fucking ignore them,
then they win.
I mean,
it's a possibility that they could win.
There's no way.
Look,
when you get sued,
you get sued.
He got to respond.
But you know,
let's just say,
we said,
look,
you guys obviously haven't done the math on our company,
but you know,
it's,
it's a business.
No one wants to spend the time and the 1 million plus dollars to fight this
thing,
you know,
take 350 grand and please go away or 500 grand or a hundred grand,
whatever it is.
Well how long before they go to iTunes and they go,
oh,
let's see who else is doing okay over here on iTunes and they take a piece of
steel in all right.
Now,
last time we did this with Corolla,
we got 500 k out of him when we chose good for and all we got to do is do the
same thing we did with Corolla.
He knows,
I mean we'll let,
we'll let Joe's attorneys coach 'em up,
but they're going to tell you this,
the most expensive kind of litigation is going to cost over a million dollars.
I mean,
he can go on the Internet and looked at them.
Do you know that these human beings are behind this?
Do you know the actual human beings?
Uh,
are you aware of names or faces?
You know what they look like?
No,
I don't.
And I never think that way.
Like I,
I just think that I understand that we live in a world that is generally decent
and that these people probably think of themselves as generally decent.
You know,
they probably have kids that love them and a wife that,
uh,
it gives him a blowjob on occasion.
This is what they do for living.
This is their business.
And I think when a guy works at a used RV lot and he's got an Rv on that lot
that's worth $4,000 and some elderly couple comes in there and he gets them for
20 grand,
he doesn't go home and stare in the mirror and go,
wow,
I'm a really bad human being.
He goes,
I'm a fucking great salesman.
And I think that's what these guys do.
I don't even fault them.
And on a personal level,
like they make money from doing this,
I understand it.
Um,
it's no,
it's not even worth trying to make it a personal issue.
I don't feel it's a personal issue.
They saw my podcast,
I'm actually in a bizarre way,
flattered.
They saw my podcast and said,
that guy's really doing well for himself.
I kids go get one to 3 million bucks.
That's,
that's insane.
That was their first offering.
So it's stunning.
What we're doing is we're getting everyone together and we're going to show him
that the podcast community is a lot stronger than they thought,
that they fucked with the wrong people.
And I don't mean me,
I mean everybody and that whether you're a Joe Rogan fan or Adam Carolla fan or
an NPR fan,
it's all going away if we don't buck up and beat these guys.
So we just went to fund anything D.
Dot com forward slash pan trawl and you can give toward the legal defense fund.
This is a video up there to watch where Adam explains the whole situation and
uh,
what's going on and,
and spread this,
spread it on Twitter,
spread it on Facebook.
Let everybody know if you can't donate it,
at least spread the word and let people know what the fuck is going on because
uh,
yeah,
this is a crazy thing.
It's just a weird byproduct of our society,
right?
I don't like it,
but there's nothing we could do about it at this point in time.
No.
Other than that,
this
is really cool because this could be a seminal moment for podcasting,
which you guys fucked with the wrong guys.
We're all grassroots,
but we all band together.
We all got our little individual little armies and we all got them United and we
all fought this common cause.
You know what I love about podcasting?
That I do think that that's something that fits with the ethic of podcasting.
But I also love that podcasting isn't,
it's,
it's not a competitive thing in that everybody supports everybody else in
podcasting.
I've never heard of podcast feuds like morning Dj guys always fucking hate the
other morning Dj Guy,
right?
And they always talk shit about him.
But podcasts,
I,
I've,
I don't know anybody who says like,
you know,
uh,
we would be fucking doing great if it wasn't for that Adam Carolla show.
Everybody's watching that stupid shows sucks our podcasts is the future that
shows for old people fuck out.
You know,
that doesn't,
it doesn't seem to be going on at all.
I think the Internet,
the attitude of the Internet is that what you're dealing with the world,
you're dealing with an infinite amount of people.
It's so God damn big that having that sort of famine mentality that a lot of
people have if they are in morning radio in a specific city,
you don't need it in,
in the Internet.
No.
I listen every,
I feel like,
uh,
you know the last podcast I did yesterday,
Jay Mohr and Jo Koy were both guests on the show and they both have podcasts and
80% of the guests on my show have their own podcasts and we promote their
podcasts on my podcast.
Yes.
So that's all you need to know,
right?
We do the exact same thing and I'm always telling people,
you should do a podcast,
like people that are good guests.
I'm like,
why don't you do your own podcast all,
you don't even need a place like this.
You need a fucking MP,
three recorder and a microphone.
That's it.
Right?
Upload it online.
It takes 10 seconds and boom,
you have a fucking podcast.
Well,
the plan is podcasters unite rally your army.
And let's beat this.
Let's do it.
We're in,
we're in 1000% that's not even a real number.
It's only a hundred percent as possible.
We're in that,
but we'll say a thousand like your hyperbole.
I liked that you liked it.
So fun.
anything.com forward slash patent troll,
please go there.
If you can't donate,
please spread the word so that other people can find out about it and that can
donate.
I get it.
If you're broke,
I totally understand it.
But if you do,
uh,
appreciate podcasting and you do appreciate Adam's show and his network and he's
got a whole network.
And then on top of that,
everybody else that you know that does podcasts with,
it's Joey Diaz or Ari Shaffir or Duncan Trussell Adams,
right?
That would all go away if it wasn't for,
uh,
if,
you know,
if we can't figure out a way around this issue,
absolutely do it.
Do it ladies and gentlemen.
Okay.